once upon a time this was Greece's
future today it's a reminder of a sad
past seven thousand people crowded in
here to watch the kayak competition in
the 2004 Olympics this is where Britain
raced through Rapids to win a silver
medal for the water dried up many years
ago these days no one visits this modern
greek amphitheatre the only signs of
life are the Hawks circling overhead if
you've wondered what a 21st century
depression looks like you don't have to
go far in Greece to find out since the
games the economy has collapsed a
quarter of the working age population is
unemployed but statistics tell you
nothing about the reality of everyday
life the soulless family used to run
restaurants here in Crete now all they
have to eat the leftovers their
neighbors past him evicted from their
home and living in borrowed
accommodation the bills and iou's and
mounting I asked whether they had ever
anticipated this party a poder
port-a-potty port-a-potty machan troppo
spooks a remote EP no sauna ok Topsy
stays mutiny Yamato create ato's PT muy
k to pollute hola portes and steady tika
me pas des portes portes kaha meola on
La Jolla for families like this when
they want hope and optimism there is one
magic word limit agavia MSC reason y
como una que está murfi sonata mono
POTUS PT mu Meza Apatow spit amo Bernie
they cap surface Mona photos video
serezha it's a political phenomenon
unlike anything seen here for decades
two parties have dominated the way
Greece's run since the 1970s
now they look like being beaten in this
weekend snap elections citizens can put
their faith in to see it as a solution
is because they trust what we have been
saying all along we are talking about
sensible logical solutions at at the
same time we are talking about the
social reforms that Greece requires and
to be honest there is a change of the
political system itself the people are
fed up with old political system they
want fresh face as fresh ideas and the
fresh political institution to make the
change those fresh ideas involve taking
on the European establishment as far as
Germany is concerned there is no
renegotiation on Greece's bailout also
they say in public well we are not the
government yet but we have obviously
context to the German government
provides some time they know what we are
basic ideas are we know there's but I
think Europe has always been case for
compromise and moving forward those last
points are important first they've been
quietly talking to Berlin for some time
second they are open to a compromise
surprising perhaps until you remember
the vast majority of Greeks still want
to stay in the euro we are worrying that
the the syriza has not yet present
something concrete or something that is
realistic as far as how they are going
to deal with our partners how they are
going to deal with the main and
substantial questions of the Greek
economy that means reforms in the rest
their proposals are to our to our
understanding very much and realistic
and that this is why we are afraid that
could harm the economy this is a country
littered with remnants of its history
but most striking of all are the modern
world's vast sites that should have been
sold off years ago this is the old
Athens Airport but there haven't been
flights on and off this runway for the
past decade and a half the government
has been trying to sell this off to a
part of the privatization scheme
associated with the bailout they have a
buyer potentially they're going to build
apartments over their butts Ariza says
if it wins the election the whole thing
is off there are two separate costs in
this Greek drama those were the mega
yachts accused of paying too little tax
and those who can't avoid taxes or
afford them either for the papa darkest
family rising tyrus meant they could no
longer afford their power bills soon
enough the electricity company cut them
off open a problem for any family a
tragedy for this one after the other let
me speak with this October notes buddy
huge iguana the electricity had been
powering that L mother's life support
system she died soon after it was
switched off kills him in a polyp
arigato sensei Matta ready opinion on I
declare stepped in a linen at Renison on
a sec any Christian see me oda hodkin
asados epd acts of taco say bro he
existed after cosa bro
no coincidence that among Cerises
promises are free electricity bills for
hard-pressed families but economists
worry that all these pledges may be
irrelevant if it can't agree things with
Germany even the negotiations become
very protracted they don't seem to be
leading to anything then we can have
confidence crisis we can see bank
deposits being depleted so capital
flight social unrest and eventually
we're staring the default so really they
the time is quickly running out and by
the beginning of the summer it will be
too late this is thus Ariza campaign
post you can see it dotted around all of
Greece literally it translates as hope
is coming but there's so much hope so
much expectation bound up in one
political party that if they do get into
power and can't sort the system out what
then the worst fear is that people would
turn to real extremists neo-nazi Golden
Dawn whose protest last time around
turned violent have been banned from
open campaigning that may not stop them
from becoming the third biggest party in
Greek politics this country brought us
democracy drama tragedy this weekend all
three collide Eddie Conway Sky News in
Athens